i think we're about ready to go and get
started
as everyone continues to take their seat
i want to welcome you good afternoon
everyone i'm kim goff cruise and it is
my privilege today to welcome you to
our ceremonies as we honor our veterans
as we gather together with president
salovey provost strobel
officers of the university the
commanding officers of our naval and air
force reserve officers training corps
and all of you are honored guests
i'm also pleased to extend a special
welcome to brigadier general donald
singer and his wife ann welcome thank
you for being here
[Applause]
before we begin i would also like to
thank the yale police department color
guard for the opening ceremony thank you
very much and to share our land
acknowledgement which states
the university acknowledges the
indigenous peoples and nations including
mohegan mashintuka pequot eastern pequod
scotticoach
golden hill parkhosset niantic and the
quinnipiac and other algonquin speaking
peoples who have stewarded through
generations the lands and waterways of
what is now the state of connecticut
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship that exists between these
peoples and nations and this land
so what a pleasure to be with all of you
outside and in front of this beautifully
restored cenotaph and university
flagpole for the return of an official
ceremony to hewitt claude angle
the last two years have been challenging
to say the least with understandable
limits on how we can gather together but
somehow it feels fitting that one of our
first larger events is one in which we
can publicly recognize the important
contributions of veterans to the life of
the university
we have with us today students faculty
and staff and alumni
who have served or who are preparing to
serve
and we are grateful for the freedoms and
privileges that their sacrifices have
made possible
during our ceremony today as you'll see
on your program you will hear from a
veteran leader a current student
and we will also honor a 47-year staff
member person staff uh person not 47
years old but been here 44 47 years for
for 47 years and she supported in most
of that time and advocated for yale
veterans
our speakers and honoree represent
commitment to honor and country and to
veterans across multiple generations and
conflicts
they represent all the veterans who are
here with us today and those who care
and support them
it is my pleasure now to introduce
president peter salovey who will share
his thoughts on our treasured veterans
president salovey
[Applause]
thank you vice president goff cruz hello
everyone
thank you for being here thank you for
being here to honor veterans
past and present
it's wonderful to be together it's
wonderful to be in person together to be
on campus
and to recognize veterans day
so we're joined today by faculty staff
students and alumni who are veterans as
well as students who currently serve
in the reserve officers training court
here on yells
campus
to all of our current and former members
of the armed forces
thank you
you have our deepest gratitude and
respect
yale students alumni faculty and staff
have served their country honorably for
over three centuries
we're proud of them
we're proud of the rich legacy of
service
that they represent
we think of nathan hale yale college
class of 1773
perhaps the most famous alumnus to serve
in the american revolution
we think of cortland van rensselaer
creed the first african american to earn
a medical degree
from yale who in spite of tremendous
racism and discrimination served in the
union army during the civil war
and we think of rear admiral grace
hopper
who received her masters and phd
in mathematics from yale university
when she retired from the navy
at the age of 79
she was the oldest serving officer in
the u.s
armed forces
remembering the service and sacrifice of
veterans
is a responsibility
we all share
one hundred years ago on november 11
1921
the tomb of the unknown soldier was
dedicated in arlington national cemetery
as a place to honor and commemorate
american lives
lost in war
and yale
too
shares in this history
ferdinand
a french military leader served as
commander-in-chief of the allied armies
in world war one
spoke at arlington
at the funeral for the unknown soldier
and the next day
he traveled to new haven
where he received an honorary degree
from yale
our university knew the terrible cost of
war
all too well
here on hewitt quadrangle
the memorial cenotaph honors 225 yale
students and alumni
who died in the great war
and carved into the walls of memorial
hall
you can find the names of 1020 alumni
killed in battle
since the american revolution
yale's tradition of military service
continues with the students who
currently serve in yale rotc
and this year we are particularly
grateful for their example
of service
the pandemic has reminded us
time and time again
of the critical importance of putting
the needs of others
above our own
service is part of the yale veteran
community's dna
we see that in the work of the yale
veterans network
a campus group for students faculty and
staff
and the yale veterans association an
alumni organization
in the early days of the pandemic the
yale veterans network supported the
downtown evening soup kitchen
helping provide meals to our neighbors
in new haven
last winter they continued their
tradition of collecting toys for the u.s
marines toys for tots program
which provides gifts for children at the
holidays
the new co-chairs of the yale veterans
network sean flynn and tamika hollis
are continuing to support veterans
within the elk community while also
helping those in need in the broader
community
i thank them for their service
as we honor the contributions
and sacrifices
of all veterans
at the going down of the sun
and in the morning
we will remember them
thank you very much thank you for being
here
hold on
holly holt
ready
so
right
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
order
three grand architect
of the universe called by many names in
many languages by many voices
today we ask that your guiding hands
hold us and all sisters and brothers in
military service near
we are grateful
for all who serve
all who have served
and for those who in the words of
president abraham lincoln
gave the last full measure of devotion
and service to their country
we are joined in humility gratitude
and our own measure of devotion
knowing that as we seek to understand an
increasingly complex world
we are sheltered by the vigilant service
of citizens to our republic
we ask special regard for those who have
served but who have not yet been found
and returned home
and for those who have returned home
but who have yet to find themselves at
home
we honor our military
and ask that whatever is required of
them be informed by your infinite wisdom
the light and the truth as they
honorably and loyally seek to create a
peaceful and secure future for us all
good afternoon everyone first and
foremost i'd like to give recognition
and thanks to president salve secretary
goff cruz provost strobel chaplain
coogler tamika hollis valerie stanley
and the veterans day committee i'd also
like to personally thank dean risa soti
patricia way i'd like to thank head
david evans
dean brian bilsky and damaris cardona
berkeley college for their constant
support over the last three years
i'd also take a moment to recognize and
thank the men and women in uniform and
those
in civil service
law enforcement and the fire department
last but not least i want to thank my
incredible parents
who are here in the front row or second
row right before me my father tay and my
mother hong
it is
veterans day and we're thanking our
veterans but it's veteran families who
endure more hardship than you could
imagine and sit back in constant worry
and fear
while we're across the world during our
job doing what we love and they stay in
a state of unrest and concern not
knowing the danger we are in and what
could happen to all in attendance thank
you for coming
it's an honor to be here with you all on
this day to thank our veterans to honor
their sacrifices october 19 2001 the u.s
army's 25th ranger regiment as part of a
special operations joint task force
parachute dropped into objective rhino
in afghanistan
army rangers were then excuse me
continually deployed to combat ever
since
up until recently
that was well over 7000 days of unbroken
combat operations during this time 52
army rangers gave the ultimate sacrifice
laying down their lives over 450 were
wounded in action
many care of the physical wounds of war
almost all carry the invisible scars
they join the service whole
and often leave pieces of themselves in
these distant lands
yet they would never leave a fallen
brother behind and they will drive on to
complete the mission no matter what
an army ranger chooses this he
volunteers for it
pulling knowing the hazards of his
chosen profession
he accepts the effect as a ranger his
country expects him to move further
faster and fight harder than any other
soldier a ranger will shoulder more than
his his share of the task 100 and then
some
it's not for the money he makes not much
more than if he chose a regular 9-5
non-combat job it's not for the benefits
you get the same if he chose a less
hazardous specialty with a shorter
enlistment contract it's not for the
work-life balance he trains for seven
months and deploys for four months every
year giving up time with his family and
loved ones
so why does he do it he does it for the
man to his left and his right to protect
his loved ones back home
for all of us civilians stateside right
now
regardless of whether you support him or
not he's willing to sacrifice everything
for you many have given that ultimate
sacrifice and may they never be
forgotten i'm proud to have served the
75th ranger regiment proud of deployed
twice to afghanistan with first ranger
battalion lucky to be standing here with
you all today and grateful to all
veterans before
and after me who have answered the call
with their selfless service
my motivation to join the military
was rooted in my parents sacrifice to
leave their homes in vietnam in search
of a better life for their families they
were just kids
my father was a teenager with no other
choice but to have to leave his own
father and everything he knew behind to
embark on a dangerous journey to some
far-off land this far off land was
united states
and it gave my family an opportunity a
better life the chance to give back to
this great nation that welcomed my
family and gave them opportunity
to protect the freedom that my parents
risked their lives to have for me that
alone was worth fighting for
i remember when i finished the first
phase of ranger school
i'd lost about 15 pounds in 20 days and
had essentially been drained of all my
strength when i pitifully jogged out of
the gates
of the training compound for my 8 hour
break or pass i was in shock to see my
parents who had driven down to georgia
from new york to surprise me
due to exhaustion i don't remember much
of those next eight hours but i do
remember my mother and father caring for
me
all my fingers were infected and swollen
to the point of immobility but i do
remember coming in out of sleep to my
mother cleaning each of my fingers and
nails
i remember sitting at a buffet right
before having to go back to the training
compound
and seeing the looks on my parents faces
as they watched me struggle to simply
lift a glass of water to my mouth
the next two weeks in ranger school were
among the most physically difficult
in my life i essentially lost almost all
strength and control of my arms and
fingers i tore and retore
the ligaments my ankles repeatedly
only for me to be supported by a tight
tie of the boots
yeah every day i continued to get that
90 pound rucksack on my back and just
did what i had to do to be a
contributing member on my team
so what's the lesson here
well in hindsight if you're in that
condition it's highly recommended to go
see a physician
but i tell this story because it
highlights the first impactful lesson
from the military that i want to share
with you is the power of your why and
how important it is to not only identify
it but to never lose sight of it
never once did i consider quitting in
those weeks
when your why is strong enough the how
is irrelevant
as viktor frankl said in his book man's
search for meaning suffering ceases to
be suffering at the moment it finds a
meeting my wine range of school
remember what you promised your family
yourself and your brothers
that was my why i wrote that sentence in
sharpie underneath the brim of my patrol
cap so that every time i was feeling
sorry for myself in a low point i get
down on a knee remove the cap from my
head and read it to remind myself why i
had to keep going
over the next three months blood sweat
and dirt was stained into that cap
and when i finished the course i gave it
to my father who still has it to this
day the writing on it is blurred and
almost illegible but it can be read
often your why may be hard to see but i
promise you it's there if you look hard
enough the second lesson for my service
that i always share
do something difficult every day
why would i give so much during training
i mean this was just ranger school after
all it was in afghanistan but that's
what special operations emphasizes how
you do small things is how you do all
things
it's important to learn about who you
are at your lowest point to test your
character when at rock bottom in ranger
school i was constantly in pain and
asking myself the question many of us do
when we were facing something difficult
how long will this last
instead i encourage you to ask how far
can i go
if i couldn't push myself further then
how could i be expected to push further
when i was deployed when there was much
more in the line in combat
the only way i could truly learn about
myself and how far i could really go was
by doing something difficult every day
and that was life and range regiment
however i'll admit that was a different
environment it was easier for me to
choose difficult because there's much
more at stake than just myself
after all that was preparation for
combat
it is far far easier to choose but it's
easy when things don't go the way where
they're supposed to it is human nature
to put the blame elsewhere
so in these moments i challenge you to
look deeper than yourself
life is pain and struggle it's
inevitable in life that you'll find some
you'll find yourself facing bad
situations
but it's how you face these difficulties
that will determine your fate
your obstacles are not these things
events or people
the obstacle is yourself see the role
you played in any failure it can always
be found
as viktor frankl wrote when we are no
longer able to change the situation
we are challenged to change ourselves so
choose difficult you will learn more
about yourself and we'll be better for
it
when i left the ranger regiment and came
to yale the transition was very
difficult
at the end of my first year i wrote an
article describing some of my thoughts
as a veteran who recently left the
service
initially i did not want to publish it
but i realized that it wasn't about me i
realized that i was fortunate to be part
of an incredible institution here at
yale
privileged
to have a platform that could reach a
large audience
and that my article could serve as a
voice for all veterans out there who
don't have one
the veterans who may not want to or may
not know how to directly express their
thoughts to their friends and family
and just maybe they could possibly share
this article with them instead
if i somehow was able to reach just one
veteran with that message that would
make it all worth it
in that article i said that civilians
did not need to understand us to care
about us
however after some thought
i do believe that asking others to care
may be a bit of an overstep
i sit alongside peers that don't truly
comprehend the events of 9 11
to war is a far away concept blurred by
distance
experienced through screens
skin in the game
is one thing that goes through my mind
every time i have to evaluate someone's
motivation on a matter their capacity to
truly care
see today unlike previous generations
far fewer individuals have a direct
connection to military service
we have far fewer people who have ever
worn the uniform who've ever experienced
from the first hand perspective what it
means to serve and sacrifice but whether
they've experienced war or not it's
important to understand that veterans
willingness to surface the veterans
willingness to sacrifice everything
cannot be forgotten
it must be honored
i believe that there is much progress to
be made if individuals seek to try to
understand their veterans
so i will conclude this speech by trying
to do just that
helping others understand their veterans
even if it's just a tiny bit better
many veterans spent
large portions of their lives give their
youths to fight for the generations that
come after them
they risk their lives hoping to make way
for a better tomorrow
so that those who were not yet born
would have the opportunity to live in a
better world
some of us matured quicker because the
world showed us its dark side at a young
age
we trained and fought together
regardless of
any differences among us these were our
brothers
brotherhood had nothing to do with how
we felt about each other it didn't
matter what we thought about each other
or if we would hang out with each other
outside of work when it came down to it
we would die for each other
that's brotherhood
we served for similar reasons we signed
up and fought for those that we loved
back home fellow american citizens that
we did not know
and for those oppressed in a foreign
land
it didn't matter what race they were
what religion they believed in what side
of politics they supported none of that
mattered when we were out there what
mattered was demand to our left and
right and the core values that we were
willing to die to protect
we're not invincible as much as we
selected think and convince ourselves
that we were
war humbled us we had this idea from the
media or video games of the recruiter on
what would be so glorious about it but
once that protective bubble burst and it
suddenly sat in that death could very
much become a reality it was a humbling
experience
we don't particularly miss the war in
combat we miss the brotherhood the
camaraderie knowing exactly what we do
for each other without hesitation that
is what we miss miss the most
many veterans struggle with depression
when they return home not because they
long for the pity of others but because
they are searching again for a purpose a
why when we're over there
we dreamt about how
amazing it would be to go home but when
we get home we realized that life
carried on without us that we were never
really needed here
veterans returned what seems like a
bubble of excess materialism cynicism
and ingratitude and find themselves
shipped to the roles they spent years of
their lives devoting their blood and
sweat to over there people relied on us
we were needed even if it wasn't what we
initially volunteered for it was outside
of this country that we found a purpose
military personnel are like a strong
seal
they endure a heavy amount of pressure
and show no external signs of stress or
damage until they just break
from personal experience i can say that
the military teaches you to separate
your mind from your emotions
you cannot survive in combat unless
you've mastered this task emotional
thinking can lead to second guessing
second guessing can lead to hesitation
and hesitation could lead to injury or
death
therefore this ability is like a switch
that one must flip on and off
it spills over to one's personal life in
relationships
then you are told that you are cold
hearted because you no longer express
yourself emotionally you begin to drift
apart
it then seems that the only people that
understand or relate to you are those
with which with which you served
you find yourself closer to them than
your actual family your spouse your
civilian friends
it can lead to a very difficult time
adjusting the civilian norms
in the military in combat is imperative
to exist without emotion yet
emotions are what we are genetically
programmed to express and display in
everyday civilian life that is what
makes the life of a veteran it should be
difficult
everyone seems to love his children so
they come home they don't ask us about
our experiences for the most part not
because they don't want to disturb us
because but because they're afraid of
being disturbed by what it takes
for them to be safe and free
we sleep on we sleep sound under a warm
blackened blanket of freedom
i'm bothered not knowing that these
rough individuals will do
and go to the farthest ends to protect
us
the thought that freedom and safety is
not a given birthright is an
uncomfortable truth to the normal
civilian
you may wonder why it's so surprising to
you that some combat veterans are lost
here and want to actually go back to war
a reason to consider is that it's a
selfless society in war and
comparatively civilian life is
individualistic
soldiers who deploy it as a cohesive
unit
come back to society of individuals who
do not behave as a unit
most relationships that people have with
each other nowadays are shallow
most don't know their neighbors people
in universities often spend years seeing
each other in lectures and never come to
genuinely know each other
with technology and social media our
generation has been trained to be
isolated from human contact and each day
this creates a more isolated situation
for each
as citizens
we are responsible for a society who
must strive to have respect for things
for people that we do not understand we
must be in we must not be individuals in
society who seek echo chambers
who self-categorize and tribalize
because what this does is breaks apart
the american tapestry
you must not fail to see the big picture
and remember that there are things much
more important than ourselves such as
maintaining respect
for differing opinions and remaining
united as a nation because it is a
selfless
respectful thing to do because that
matters more to the greater good
we must not become preoccupied with
attempting to dictate change to society
before looking inside ourselves first
thus if we were more introspective and
less determined to bend the world to our
ideology we would by definition be more
unified
the question for each one of us is how
do we begin to unite
humility and perspective will be our
greatest teachers moving forward
keep humility close to your heart and
maintain perspective and together we can
solve so many more challenges in life
humility and perspective allow us to
learn from each other
i speak to you
through my fellow veterans
you are among some of the best trained
individuals in the world
you underwent a transformation as i have
in order to stay vigilant and be alive
in a place that prides itself on taking
you out without cause
you will never be the same
but the truth is you will be better
some days will be harder than others but
the peace will come in time
one day you'll realize just how far
you've come and the struggles you face
won't feel so intimidating because you
realize you've conquered so many before
even if the pain is still there you
realize it may always be and somehow
that's okay
as viktor frankl wrote what is to give
light must endure burning
when a bone breaks and aligns
incorrectly in your body
a doctor will often have to re-break it
in order for you to heal properly
the same is true for the ego
past trauma or the circumstances of the
world can cause our mind to align
incorrectly this healing may require a
breaking
i say to you it will always be okay in
the end
if it's not okay
it's not the end
think back to a year ago
do you remember what was bothering you
is it still bothering you
what you were going through will pass
use hindsight as foresight you'll be
grateful for it
when we honor veterans day when we
remember our veterans it's important for
us to remember the incalculable debt
that is owed to you to our veterans
a debt that is impossible to ever repay
fully
but it is a debt that is essential for
us to always remember to never forget
the true cost of freedom
and who carries the burden of that cost
as a fellow veteran your struggle is my
struggle
your anger and frustration are my anger
and frustration your pain is my pain
your challenges are my challenges your
failures and successes are my failures
and successes
my service pails in comparison to great
individuals who've come before me who've
paved the way
to true warriors like bobby atkinson sam
mayers james hatch
excuse me who also attend this great
university and provide more value than
most will ever know
i'm not a hero i serve with real heroes
those who wake up every single day at 5
a.m and put their boots in uniform on
where nobody has any idea where they're
at or the things they're doing and to
those who can never return
and for the gold star families who carry
on today without sons daughters fathers
and mothers i honor you
to staff sergeant jason dalkey
private cla first class eric carrio
corporal andrew amesbury staff sergeant
ivanya chisholm china first class
christopher solis
specialist at tian murphy sergeant first
class ethan carpenter these are just a
few great men
who serve as part of my reason why today
and every day
to all the veterans who have served
thank you for your sacrifices you've
made and continue to make
you have given this country
a privilege that is beyond payment
we honor you for that today and every
day thank you
hurry
okay
foreign
hey
[Music]
[Music]
so
i don't know about you i feel the need
to just kind of like breathe for just a
second that was very very impactful
speech andrew thank you very much
as well
[Music]
from time to time the university
recognizes outstanding contributions to
veterans with the veterans day tribute
award
and this year is my great honor to
present the award to valerie stanley
senior director of the office of
institutional equity and accessibility
now in a moment valerie will make her
way here so we can actually give her a
war but ashley's doing i want to tell
you a little bit about why the committee
thought this was appropriate
many of you may know the valerie has
been on staff for 47 years as i
mentioned that's like 47 years
and for 44 of those years she has been
involved in crafting policy and plans to
comply with federal requirements in
areas including title vi
the ada title ix section 504 and age
discrimination
to name a few
in fact in the late 1970s
valerie helped write the university's
first affirmative action and equal
opportunity plan for the united states
department of health education and
welfare
she worked 14 straight days
using typewriters and carbon paper
now if you don't know what that is you
can just see me later okay
but what many of you may not know is
that valerie has also been for all of
those years an outstanding and a really
long-term ally for our veterans
in her early days she had a special
affinity and affection for vietnam
veterans who often felt unwelcome on
their return
and were hesitant to share their service
and experience with yale colleagues
she would support them and she continues
to support them however she could
in 2011 valerie began working with
debbie stanley mcauley who's the
associate vice president for employee
engagement and workplace culture
and she worked to advocate for the
creation of a new affinity group on
campus for staff veterans
as a result we now have the yale
veterans network
a yale community of veterans veteran
leaders and allies who support and
encourage each other in addition to
advocating for veteran recruitment
career development growth and retention
and today that network
the vl veterans network is thriving
and valerie serves and continues to
serve on its steering committee
in addition to supporting these veterans
valerie has made a point to help yale
students in particular understand the
veteran experience
valerie you're going to retire in
december
after 47 years at yale
but before you go
i am so pleased to present you with this
award on behalf of the veterans day
committee and the university
in recognition of your support your
long-term report support for veterans at
yale
please join me
and
in accepting the small token of our
admiration and respect let me see find
it
and your contributions thank you very
very much
thank you kim and thank you everyone i
don't have a prepared speech but i do
want to just express
my sincere
thanks to the veterans committee for
choosing me today i'm not a veteran i
don't have a story andrew has the
perfect wonderful story and all the rest
of you who have served this country have
equally important and wonderful stories
even if you haven't had the opportunity
to share them with anybody else maybe
you have with your family maybe no one
maybe it's just something that's in your
head but your stories are all important
everything you've done is important
all i've tried to do is to support you
in the best way that i could in the best
way that i know how and i am truly truly
honored
to accept this award from you all in
this recognition
after i was only two when i started so
that's my story i'm sticking to it those
of you who know me for a while now i've
had that story for a long time
um but anyway thank you all so much it
is truly an honor and a pleasure i'm
going to miss you all
but i live in new haven i'll be around
and i'm sure i'll see some of you around
thank you
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
haha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
so
[Applause]
i invite you to stand please for the
benediction
let us go forth from this place of
profound memory
and deep meaning with grateful hearts
grateful for the service and sacrifice
of our veterans and their families
let us never forget all they have done
to bravely protect freedom and human
rights
from the moment our veterans made the
commitment to serve they were committing
to a life
that would be forever changed
may we be ever mindful that the life of
a veteran is always multi-dimensional
and is rooted in the pride and promise
of liberation coupled with the
ever-present possibility of peril or
alienation
all of these things are held in tension
and contain a longing for a certain kind
of peace
to revive our weary world
as we honor our veterans
and we seek to grow closer to this
abiding peace
may we come to know
a peace born from wisdom and
understanding
a peace nurtured with compassion and
mercy
a peace strengthened by courage
and commitment
and may we be blessed this day and every
day
by the shimmering light of our god of
many names
our god who creates sustains and
embraces all life for this we say amen
oh god oh tom
forward
well this concludes our ceremony
and with day is passed we and we return
to our busy life i hope that we will
continue to remember the women and men
of yale who have faithfully taken oaths
to protect and serve
remember that they are the reason why we
can pursue our whys and why we can
build a
better community we are stronger and
diverse
community because of them
many thanks to the planning committee
and our ceremony participants as well
and special thanks to tom duffy and the
yale school of music brass ensemble for
sharing with us moving inspiring music
thank you for all that you do
thank you everybody and enjoy your day